[Music]
the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
but you're open to that ideally i am
tonight on politics now the race for
governor we sit down with current
governor steve sisolak to talk about why
he would break up ccsd lifting the mass
mandate and rising crime
steve siselek destroyed many lives
republican challenger michelle fiori
talks about the pandemic and why the fbi
seized some of her records
do you think iowa loses its its sort of
number one slot
plus presidential race jockeying we
catch up with the political director
from our sister station in des moines
iowa as nevada tries to beat iowa to the
front of the primary line
from 8 news now this is politics now
[Music]
thank you for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler governor
steve sisilak he is fresh off lifting
nevada's mass mandate tonight we sit
down with the governor to talk about the
upcoming re-election campaign crime and
education
the campaign's underway certainly on the
gop side of things you haven't really
talked too much about the campaign if at
all
so far
when are you planning to really sort of
start actually campaigning to keep your
job well we're campaigning every single
day i'm on the community uh my primary
focus now has been obviously fighting
covid we've got our hands full fighting
coven trying to keep our kids in school
and our business is open not overwhelm
the health care system but i am
certainly running for election i'm on
community and we've got a team put
together and it's growing every single
day and looking forward to it you
certainly have a something of a record
war chest right now
what have you taken away from your
potential opponents uh in the general
election
what you've seen of them anyway well you
know i've watched it on the republican
side there's a lot of them you know it's
got to have a scorecard sometimes to
keep track who's in there uh they're
seem to be spending most of their time
right now attacking me and criticizing
me as opposed to each other and maybe
they don't understand to appeal that
their base they're gonna have to start
talking about each other but we've got a
lot of accomplishments that i think we
can run upon and i'm looking forward to
it and i'm sure it'll be a exciting
election season
you recently ended the mass mandate in
public places uh here in nevada uh you
kind of addressed this certainly during
the press conference after the
announcement but just talk about again
why now
well you know it was why now some people
think it was too early some people think
it was too late uh basically some people
said i'm dead if i did and damned if i
didn't you know when it came to the
masks and when it came to the vaccines
and when it came to the testing when it
came to various things we made decisions
in consultation with our uh our business
community in consultation with our
medical community and advisors and so
forth cases were dropping some criticism
from sheriff joe lombardo who you
obviously know running as republican for
governor uh specific with crime crime is
up here in southern nevada especially he
cites the lack of of certain sentencing
regulations that sort of handcuffs
pardon the pun law enforcement when
they're trying to uh punish
those who have committed crimes
what do you say to the criticism of the
the changing and sentencing guidelines
that maybe some might say
is
leading to it the crime on the back end
increasing well i don't know what he's
talking about when he's talking about
the changing in the sentencing we have
several bipartisan uh criminal justice
bills go through that i want to point
out the sheriff never opposed or metro
never opposed when they're going through
it that's the time you need to make your
opinions known if you'd felt strongly
about it you should have gone to carson
city and made his feelings known he did
not do that metro did not do that we had
a bipartisan bill that was passed as it
relates to
some criminal justice reforms i think
it's going to be better in the long run
i'm confident of that but the crime
problem murders homicides are an
all-time high i mean they've gone up
what 45 50 percent in the last year
that's not something that came out of my
office that's something that came out
the sheriff's office and i think that
they need to look within in terms of
getting a handle on that ccsd was in
distance learning longer than any other
district i'm pretty sure in the state
there's been long talks by those on the
republican side certainly to try and
break up ccsd you've heard that
discussion for years and years and years
would you entertain that idea if you
were reelected as governor of the idea
of splitting up clark county school
district certainly you know i want to
know what parents want to do and i've
talked to a lot of parents uh my kids
were part of the clark county school
district they went to durango high
school and it was it's a big school i
mean when you went to talk to your
counselor you got one counselor for you
know 900 students i mean it's not
exactly a great ratio uh i'm definitely
in support of that i i know the parents
the one good thing that came out of this
or one of the good things that came out
of the pandemic is parents are much more
involved in the kids educations right
now in terms of voicing an opinion and
what they'd like and i think parents
would like to see the school district
broken up one of the problems you get
with breaking it up if you've got some
affluent areas if you're talking about
summerlin or green valley then you've
got the urban core well everybody
deserves access the same quality
education so you'd have to come up with
a plan so that all students would have
the ability to get a quality education
but what else do you would you tackle
if you're re-elected as governor uh what
would be sort of top on your agenda
besides those sort of two aspects well
there's one that kind of takes in
several things the affordability of
housing also includes homelessness as
far as i'm concerned we need to start
looking at that you know we've made the
american dream for young people coming
up the dream of owning your own home and
you know building up equity and
retirement has almost become impossible
i mean entry-level homes in reno for
starter homes over half a million
dollars just to get in the door and
southern nevada is bumping right up
against a half million dollar number
that's not really a viable scenario for
someone that's getting a job making even
twenty or twenty five dollars an hour
now governor sislak is the latest of
many politicians on both sides of the
political aisle to float breaking up
clark county school district we're going
to delve a lot deeper into that issue in
later editions of politics now
speaking of the race for governor it is
a crowded field of 10 republicans trying
to win the chance to face off against
governor sisalek in the general election
las vegas city councilwoman michelle
fiore she is one of them she has been
third or fourth in fundraising and
polling so far
fiore has a history of making
controversial statements and i started
off by asking her about an fbi raid on
her office in 2021 we should note though
no charges have been filed
you're under a federal investigation
right now
foreign why would you say something like
that did you verify that with the fbi
well well then help me understand let's
clear the air because it's been reported
definitely clear the air go for it all
right you need to any investigative
journalist needs to literally call the
fbi and verify that i'm under
investigation because they're not going
to tell you i'm under investigation now
did i talk to them a year ago absolutely
absolutely i spoke with the fbi they had
some questions and you know what they
they're an agency um and when they ask
you questions you answer them but but
when you want to turn around and say i'm
under fbi investigation unless you
verify that with that that particular
agency that's not a fair statement okay
so you're not under federal
investigation you're saying i would say
not okay
uh how many times had the fbi now i'm
this has been reported yeah raided your
house or your office so first of all the
fbi raid okay
the fbi did not raid my house so a year
ago on january 27 the fbi knocked on my
door came in my house looted robbed and
rated it on on january 27th so it wasn't
a raid
and this was over a year ago so you know
that's that's the answer that you want
that's the answer you're going to get
because it's always going to be the
truth you have touted in the past in
your long career in politics here that
you've never been politically correct
yep i'm not going to start
and that you don't plan to start
why do you believe that is a good
quality to have in the governor's
mansion because you need to be truthful
with the people
right so as um
as the person that represents the people
sometimes
well not sometimes a lot of times
elected officials will not be truthful
with the people
and they'll do what they're told
by whom they think
and without asking the people for their
opinions or their advice so sometimes
when you speak with
our constituents here in the state of
nevada
i think being truthful
will always be
the right answer and whether it's
popular or not
and whether you say it in a politically
correct way i think that we owe it to
nevadans to always let them know what's
going on
on the point of the pandemic
as governor if you were governor at the
beginning of the pandemic how would you
have done things differently than
governor sisilak i wouldn't have shut
the state down number one i wouldn't
have put people out of work number two i
wouldn't have mandated vaccines where
now they were forced to resign our
nurses and teachers number three number
four our unemployment system it wasn't
the director's problems why he kept
firing people to make himself look good
that was all our antiquated systems our
antiquated systems that weren't paying
people their unemployment check because
they were forced their companies were
forced to shut down steve sisalak
destroyed many lives in the process of
his emergency orders that he took total
advantage of
murder crime they're up big concerns the
violent crime rates going up what would
you do to deal with that issue as
governor um whether it comes to laws or
funding or whatever the case may be with
regards to law enforcement i would make
sure that they're funded i would make
sure that the handcuffs on our police
are off right what kind of handcuffs
well i'll give you a great for instance
these protests right were they protests
or were they violent breaking our
windows putting things on fire i mean
they're calling them peaceful protests
that's not peaceful right and what did
what did our governor do he marched with
him what's it what's its what did joe
lombardo do when we wanted to do a blue
lives matter march right now we're law
abiding we're not going to be breaking
things we're sweet we're going to march
down las vegas boulevard for our cops
joe lombardo calls me up and says
michelle you can't do this protest you
can't do this march but yet the domestic
terrorist group organization black lives
matter got to do theirs you know why
because they didn't ask permission
right
just tobacco are you suggesting that the
black lives matter movement is domestic
terrorist without a doubt 100
their display
of what they did right they can march
all day long right but when you break
minority businesses shoot cops
when you when you don't think that's
domestic terrorism
there's a lot more to that in fact we
asked fiori about her relationship with
fellow city councilwoman victoria seaman
and a reported physical altercation
between the two she said she wouldn't
get physical with anyone first but
called her a friend
now full interviews with governor
sysolak and councilwoman mcfiori they
are on 8newsnow.com you can also watch
our other discussions with the
gubernatorial candidates so far
in other political news one big factor
in the election is how voters think
about president joe biden the latest
poll from civics has as you see over my
screen here 56 percent disapproval
versus 34 percent approval for the
entire country here in nevada it's about
the same as you see here 57 percent
disapprove of the president's
performance so far 35 percent approve
among independents here in nevada 67
percent disapprove of the president's
performance so far in his term 25
percent approved numbers to watch as the
political season continues along
next on politics now will nevada take
the top spot we'll tell you what's going
on behind the scenes in iowa that could
vault nevada to the front of the
presidential welcome back to politics
now
the democratic national committee may
shuffle its presidential nominating
process iowa and new hampshire are
traditionally the first two states
followed by nevada both nevada and
iowa's caucuses as you'll remember back
in 2020 had technical issues
after that here in nevada we switched to
a primary and passed a bill trying to be
the first state to help decide a
candidate
the next presidential election seems a
long way off but we're already starting
to look ahead because there are some
changes possibly and how the primary
system works here dave price is joining
us from our sister station at who in des
moines iowa because dave this chance
iowa won't be first anymore dave thank
you for joining us here what is the
state of play from iowa's point of view
on where things might fit in with the
presidential campaigns
i would say nervous
and i think
i've been here 20 years now but i think
this is probably the most nervous
that party officials have been have
become here on either side here
obviously most of the nerves are on the
democratic side this time around
and there's a lot of brainstorming going
on behind the scenes and there's not a
lot of public comments if you will even
from folks who normally talk a lot
right now they're trying to figure out
do we come up with a new strategy
they're looking ahead to that march
meeting with the democratic national
committee members there and they realize
that iowa is really really under the gun
so they're looking at whether they need
to possibly even change the format of
the caucuses one way or the other as a
way to maybe say this you know nevada
officials have tried for a long time to
try and uh get ahead in in the in the
whole schedule of events a lot of folks
here certainly would think that nevada's
maybe more representative of the country
in terms of trying to pick a
presidential candidate why is iowa so
eager to stay first in this in the
presidential campaigns
yeah and you know i think iowans have
been listening to that criticism for a
long time it's still primarily a very
white state it's changing
but still very white now what democrats
in particular will say is look at the
last several winners here
there was a black man barack obama who
won
there was a woman hillary clinton who
won there was a gay man pete buttigieg
who won so those are the last three
democratic caucus winners so they say
yes
overwhelmingly this is a white state
where most people are white
the non-white population is growing and
frankly growing a lot faster
than the white population so they think
that ought to that ought to count for
something they like the fact that it's a
good mix of urban and rural
and they think that despite the fact
that there are a lot of white people
here
democrats who turn out are diverse in
thought and are welcoming for all
backgrounds of people and they think
that should count for something when the
dnc makes this decision
do you think iowa loses its its sort of
number one slot
that's what they really have to they
hope not they they know that there's a
decent chance that could happen
that's why they know
from
from a realistic standpoint the caucus
of last cycle will probably not be the
way it looks for the next cycle no
matter how this plays out there will
likely be some adjustments and that's
what party officials are discussing this
month do they come up with a different
way to do this to try to get more people
to take uh to be involved here
for example
but they're clearly nervous and they
know that they may have to look at
options they would never consider before
do they share it with another state so
like nevada for example here a more
diverse state that's also using a
primary does it make more sense for iowa
and
nevada to go first and then maybe it's
new hampshire and south carolina
whatever it is so they realize they're
going to have to think about some other
alternatives here but bottom line they
want to try to come up with whatever
they can do to try to keep it first
even if maybe they would have to share
it with somebody else
very interesting dave price from our
sister station in des moines who thank
you very much for your insight good to
see you
other political news another republican
entering the race for nevada attorney
general commercial real estate attorney
tisha black is now a candidate for the
post she says she wants to support
second amendment rights and fight
overreach from washington d.c
fellow republican seagal chatta quickly
responded to the announcement she calls
black a democratic plant china has
gained notoriety for lawsuits she's
filed against coronavirus mandates some
of those lawsuits she has won
is another war on the horizon next on
politics now senator jackie rosen
discusses the ongoing dispute between
russia and ukraine plus
why inflation could get worse and what
lawmakers are doing about it i'm hannah
brandt in washington i'll have that
you're watching politics now
[Music]
overseas russia is still threatening to
invade ukraine troops are conducting
exercises on the border as you see
diplomatic tensions are high nevada
democratic senator jackie rosen is on
the armed services and homeland security
committees
united states is number one going to
exhaust every diplomatic solution to
this problem because we
don't want to have anybody risk their
lives and we surely don't want to have
anyone go to war with that being said
we also want to be sure that vladimir
putin understands that we will not allow
him to have any more aggressive behavior
he's posturing in the region we know
over a hundred thousand troops he's been
moving them around doing various
exercises we want to let our nato allies
and partners know that we stand with
them and let vladimir putin know we're
going to stand up against him
senator rosen is also a co-sponsor of a
bill that would economically sanction
some russian banks and some top russian
military officials
here at home economic leaders warn
inflation could get worse but they
disagree about what to do with that
washington reporter hannah brant breaks
down the arguments
if russia invades ukraine it could cost
the u.s i will not pretend this will be
painless
there could be impact on our energy
prices this warning comes as inflation
is already surging something republicans
like senator rob portman blame partly on
the spending included in the american
rescue plan you can't just throw the
stimulus in
and change the policies on the supply
side as well and not expect inflation to
rage senator mitch mcconnell connects
high energy costs to the president's
policies including shutting down the
keystone xl pipeline and limiting
offshore drilling and if the president
is serious about providing relief for
americans at the pump or blunting
putin's manipulation of energy markets
he will stop his administration's
anti-energy policies democrats say they
are actively looking for solutions and
senate leader chuck schumer suggests
republicans do more than just complain
republicans seem to have no solutions
just rhetoric these challenges demand
action
and democrats remain laser focused on
lowering costs one thing democrats are
considering is a temporary federal gas
tax holiday and senator bob casey says
americans want the policies that
democrats are pushing having their child
care costs go down could help
provide some relief
having other costs get on the
prescription price of prescription drugs
should go down senator rick scott thinks
the solution comes down to cutting
regulations stop spending money stop
making it difficult to open and build a
business stop making it difficult to run
a business in washington i'm hannah
brant
democratic senator kirsten gillibrand is
making sure nominees for top defense
positions will look into unidentified
aerial phenomena unexplained video like
these here well they were at the center
of a recent report now this is her
questioning the nominee for the defense
department inspector general this week
if confirmed can i have your commitment
to sustain this comprehensive assessment
until it reaches its appropriate
conclusion including the possibility of
follow-on actions such as audits or
investigations if the assessment
recommends as much
well well again i honestly am not
familiar with that particular review but
as is typical i think across the ig
community when a new ig comes in if
they're pending matters those would
continue in in the office and it would
be perfectly appropriate to examine them
um and if i am confirmed i can assure
you that anything that's pending went
out in the office i'll give my best
attention to
so that nominee is robert storch senator
gillibrand was instrumental in getting
the uap study into the defense bill
next on politics now the next scotus
supreme court justice when we can expect
president joe biden to name a nominee
this weekend what to watch a potential
supreme court nominee president joe
biden said he would nominate a black
woman to the post to replace retiring
justice stephen breyer the president did
say he's done a deep dive on four
possible supreme court candidates
however he has not named a final nominee
just yet he has a self-imposed end of
february deadline and of course that is
right around the horizon we'll certainly
keep an eye on that it is something to
watch
we thank you so much for watching
politics now don't forget you can stay
up to date on all the political news
online just head to
8newsnow.com we're back with you next
saturday thank you so much for watching
take care
[Music]